de prendre des décisions pour moi,
fondées sur sa perception de mon meilleur intérêt,
indépendamment de ce que moi, patiente, souhaite ou crois.
Il profite de cette occasion pour sortir
et discuter de mon cas avec mon chirurgien potentiel.
À travers la porte, je l'entends me décrire comme une petite fille.
Je me suis sentie si injuriée,
j'ai voulu me défendre.
J'ai voulu expliquer clairement à chacun de ces prestataires de soins
que la manière dont ils me traitaient était méprisante et sexiste,
et que je n'avais pas à l'accepter.
Mais, j'ai encaissé.
J'ai ravalé tous mes mots durs,
serré les dents et à la place,
j'ai répondu à chacune de leurs condescendantes questions
et déclarations.
J'étais venue là pour recevoir objectivité et soutien.
Au lieu de cela, je me suis sentie rejetée et réduite au silence,
et je me détestais à cause de ça.
Je détestais le fait que je permettais aux gens
de me manquer de respect de façon répétée.
Mais, c'était mon unique chance.
Ce fut une consultation parmi les nombreuses consultations
auxquelles j'ai dû me rendre.
À un moment, j'ai rencontré jusqu'à six médecins en une seule heure.
La porte vers la salle d'examen évoquait la porte d'une voiture de clown.
Voici mon médecin principal,
et voici son collègue,
et le directeur du service.
C'était comme si je leur demandais de me contaminer avec la varicelle,
au lieu de... je ne sais pas... obtenir une méthode contraceptive.
Mais, je n'ai pas vacillé.
J'ai persévéré,
et j'ai finalement convaincu l'un d'eux
d'autoriser la procédure.
Alors que je suis en train de signer les formulaires de consentement,
de recevoir les piqûres d'hormones et de régler les derniers détails,
mon médecin secoue la tête en signe de désapprobation :
« Vous changerez d'avis ! »
Je n'avais jamais vraiment compris
à quel point cette société s'accroche à ce rôle,
avant de traverser ces épreuves.
J'ai subi, en première ligne,
de manière répétée,
l'incapacité des gens, qu'ils soient fournisseurs de soins,
collègues ou étrangers,
leur réelle incapacité de faire une séparation entre moi, la femme,
et moi, la mère.
J'ai toujours cru qu'avoir des enfants
était le prolongement de la féminité, pas sa définition.
Je crois
que les valeurs d'une femme ne devraient jamais être déterminées
par le fait qu'elle ait ou non un enfant,
car c'est la dépouiller de son identité d'adulte en tant que telle.
Les femmes ont cette capacité incroyable de créer la vie
mais affirmer que c'est leur finalité,
revient à affirmer que leur existence toute entière
est un moyen pour une fin déterminée.
Il est si facile d'oublier que les rôles que la société nous confère
sont bien davantage que de simples titres.
Qu'en est-il du poids qui les accompagne ?
De la pression pour se conformer à ces standards ?
Des peurs associées au fait d'en douter ?
Et des désirs que nous ignorons pour les accepter ?
Il y a de nombreux chemins vers le bonheur et l'épanouissement.
Ils paraissent tous très différents,
mais,
je suis convaincue que chacun d'eux
est pavé du droit au libre arbitre.
Je souhaite que les femmes sachent :
votre choix d'accepter ou de renoncer à la maternité
n'est, en aucune façon, lié à votre valeur ou à votre identité
en tant qu'épouse,
en tant qu'adulte,
ou en tant que femme.
Il y a, sans l'ombre d'un doute, un choix derrière la maternité,
et c'est le vôtre,
et le vôtre uniquement.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)